this is more than just a Snapchat filter
it's called Deep fake technology and
it's how Harrison Ford was made to look
40 years younger in the new film Indiana
Jones 5 and how the film's budget hit
almost 300 million dollars let's take a
look at how this process works and why
they decided to do this for nd5 starting
with the fact that Harrison Ford is now
80 years old which some people argue is
too old to continue playing a leading
role in an action-adventure movie but
first you might be wondering what is
deep fake technology and the basic
answer is that it's a way of using
artificial intelligence to manipulate
images and videos of people making them
look or sound like someone else the term
deep fake comes from combining deep
learning and fake as deep learning is a
type of machine learning that uses
neural networks to learn from data and
generate realistic outputs deep fake
technology can be used for various
purposes such as entertainment education
journalism or even malicious intent for
example you may have seen some viral
videos of Tom Cruise on Tick Tock where
he appears to be doing some funny and
unexpected things like biting into a
lollipop with gum inside that's
incredible but these videos are not
really Tom Cruise they're deep fakes
created by Visual and AI effects artist
Chris ume with the help of actor Miles
Fisher who looks a lot like Tom Cruise
Uma used a software called metaphysic AI
which automates hyper real generative AI
content creation the result is a series
of stunningly realistic videos of Tom
Cruise that fooled millions of viewers
on tiktok umay and Fisher didn't
monetize their account on Tick Tock but
they did launch a company called
metaphysic in June 2021 which aims to
use deep thick technology for ethical
and creative applications one of the
most anticipated applications of this
technology is de-aging actors in movies
this isn't a new concept as Hollywood
has been using various methods to make
actors look younger for decades such as
makeup Prosthetics CGI or even hiring
younger versions of the actors but deep
fake technology offers a new level of
realism and flexibility that could
potentially save time and money for
filmmakers for example instead of hiring
a younger actor to play Harrison Ford in
flashbacks or using CGI to digitally
erase his wrinkles they can use deep
fake technology to make him look just
like he did in the original Indiana
Jones movies which is exactly what they
did for Indiana Jones 5 which features
Harrison Ford reprising his iconic role
as The Adventurous archaeologist but
also includes scenes where he appears as
his younger self to achieve this
de-aging effect the filmmakers used a
deep fake technology software much like
metaphysic to create photorealistic
faces of Harrison Ford at different ages
and integrate them into the production
camera feed with minimal latency they
also used voice synthesis and mouth
manipulation to make his voice sound
younger however not everyone is happy
with this decision some fans have
criticized the use of deep fake
technology in Indiana Jones 5 arguing
that it's unnecessary unnatural or even
disrespectful to Harrison Ford's legacy
but Indiana Jones 5 isn't the first
movie to use deep thick technology to
de-age or replace actors in fact there
have been several examples of deep fake
technology in Hollywood in recent years
some more successful than others for
instance in 2019 the Sci-Fi Action film
Gemini man used this technology to
create a younger version of Will Smith
who played both the protagonist and his
clone the film used a combination of
motion capture CGI and deep learning to
create a photorealistic digital double
of Smith that could perform alongside
him another example is the 2019 crime
drama the Irishman in which use deep
fake technology to de-age Robert De Niro
Al Pacino and Joe Pesci for flashback
scenes the film used a technique called
de-aging by performance which involves
capturing the actor's facial expressions
and then applying them to their younger
selves using a neural network however
not all deep thick experiments in
Hollywood have been well received in
2016 the sci-fi film Rogue one a Star
Wars story used deep thick technology to
recreate the late Peter Cushing as Grand
Moff Tarkin and a young Carrie Fisher as
Princess Leia the film faced backlash
from critics and fans who thought the
digital characters landed Somewhere In
The Uncanny Valley the budget for
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny is
reported to have reached nearly 300
million dollars making it the most
expensive film in the Indiana Jones
franchise as well as one of the most
expensive films ever made hitting eighth
on the list surpassed only by big budget
Pirates and superhero films the biggest
Factor behind this huge budget is likely
the use of deep fake technology if you
look at the budgets of previous Indiana
Jones movies or even all of lucasfilm's
movies it tops the list by a huge margin
with some estimates placing the cost of
D aging Harrison Ford at up to a hundred
million dollars there are several other
factors that contributed to the film's
high budget besides the Deep thick
technology though one of them is the
salary of Harrison Ford who reportedly
earned 65 million dollars for Israel
making him one of the highest paid
actors in Hollywood another factor is
the production delays caused by the kova
19 pandemic which forced the film to
postpone its filming and release dates
several times increasing the cost of
logistics security and insurance
additionally the film had to deal with
some unexpected challenges and accidents
during filming such as Ford injuring his
shoulder during a fight scene a crew
member testing positive for covid-19 and
a stunt man being injured in a
motorcycle chase the film also features
some elaborate action sequences such as
a train chase a car chase and a plane
crash all these factors combined made
Indiana Jones 5 one of the most
ambitious and costly films ever made
however this also means that the film
has to perform exceptionally well at the
box office to break even and make a
profit According to some estimates the
film needs to earn at least 800 million
worldwide to be considered a success
despite the mixed reactions from fans
and critics Harrison Ford has defended
the use of deep fake technology in
Indiana Jones 5. in a press conference
at the 2020 3 can film festival where he
received an honorary Palm to ore Ford
praised the technology for being very
realistic and emotionally real I know
that that is my face it's not a kind of
Photoshop magic that's what I looked
like 35 years ago because lucasfilm has
every frame of film that we've made
together over all these years in this
process this scientific mining of this
Library this was put to good use he said
Ford also said that he was happy with
his age and didn't want to relive his
youth he said that he came back to his
role as Indiana Jones to round out the
story and that he might take a break
after the film but what do you think of
this use of deep fake technology drop
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
for more videos like this